this next comment hasn't even performed
but i'm already laughing
please give a warm welcome this is a
true legend
to the goal oh my god
hello everyone it's so great to be here
i'm judy gold
uh i'm at my favorite club bananamores
woo
so uh how's everyone been doing good
yeah it's been it's been incredible last
uh
several months you know skovid the
pandemic but you know there is one good
thing
is that my car is getting four months to
the gallon
so uh yeah it's been really tough i i
i've been uh since you know so many
stores were closed for so long i was
doing
so much shopping online you know and i
bought so much stuff from amazon
it was amazing because you know i'd be
up all night and i'd be
looking at stuff and then two days later
i'd open the door and i'd be like
oh i i did put that in my cart
but you know you know what i want to
know
who taught the people at amazon how to
pack a box
what is going on there what goes on in
that warehouse
hey guys guys we got a tweezer here
i'm gonna need a 12 by 26 box let's go
come on folks it's a slanted tweezer
let's go i need some of that plastic
with the air in it come on
move it the zoom stuff is pretty
interesting too everyone's doing
everything virtually
virtually virtually but i have to say
i've done a bunch of zoom stuff
and saying goodbye on zoom
it's like the longest jewish goodbye
do you ever notice it's like okay well
this was great
all right i'll talk to you soon okay all
right
no still here still here hey okay
leave meeting again how about the um
have you ever been on a zoom and uh the
person has no idea they're on mute and
they're completely emoting to you
that's my favorite
[Applause]
oh you're muted oh so
sorry but uh yeah so that's it for me
tonight it is
uh always an honor to perform at
bananamores
don't forget to uh tip your servers um
try the veal and i will be here all
i think forever good night folks
incredible that animos is lucky to have
you
[Music]
you